yo what's up roomie and I'm back so in
this video I'm going to talk to you
about how I built a personal chat bot
for myself yes I go to go to me chat pod
how I've leveraged this chat bot to
scale my reach and build my brand as you
probably noticed from the past videos
I'm not just a serial entrepreneur I am
a maker so I love building things and
taking my ideas to MVP to launching them
to getting feedback and turn them into
revenue generating startups or if I
understand this not something people do
not want and there I'm going to charge
money I pay for simply shut it down also
something that I would say and this is
more recently which really is something
that I enjoy is actually documenting the
process sharing as much as I can about
the process of going from idea to
revenue generating startups so they're
doing this the best way to do it is
obviously through content
one of the recent builds that I did is
or chopped up gently down here the
previous video I did on our chat bot but
I built our chat bot in the open and
really just kind of let him go and
follow along the feedback I got from it
it was amazing
people loved seeing me take an idea to
chat bot - literally generating
thousands of messages via this chat bot
and eventually turning this into
something more than just an idea an
initial kind of MVP so after I did this
build I also really became convinced in
the power of chat BOTS you know with
chat BOTS I immediately saw how I could
kind of leverage this conversational
design that chat BOTS have with other
concepts and so I knew that I needed to
then build another track lock now I was
kind of thinking you know what should i
bill and I didn't really just want to
build another standalone product that
didn't kind of benefit everything I was
already doing and I'd also think you
know thought about my personal kind of
open content that I put out and my
personal brand and I just realized that
you know how beneficial it would be for
me to build a you ever be chat line now
one of the first reasons why I thought
this would be beneficial is because it's
basically social platforms consolidated
into one so everyone's like hey be
omnipresent across all all social
platforms and get your content you know
purposed across everything and I was
just thinking like that's a lot to keep
up with of course I tried the
omnipresent but I really want one kind
of one place to send one message in this
route you know the highest quality
message I could and it's make it easier
for people to not have to like follow me
on everything so I thought facebook
Messenger would be a perfect place to do
this because I can kind of package up
all the channels and all the content
into this chat bot this would be
ultimately ultimately the kind of
centralized place where I would want to
put a feel to all right now the other is
it that I thought was the ability to
control the narrative so that's
something when you know you have content
across all the channels it can kind of
become fragmented and then the message
can also become fragmented so having
this lunch I know would allow me to
control what I wanted to tell people and
that narrative and then ultimately how
its received which of course is very
beneficial when you're trying to get
something out to people and then people
ad scale the other that I was thinking
about which is a big benefit of having a
personal chat bot is you know people
spend all their time on Facebook like
let's admit you and I both spend a ton
of time on Facebook and when you get
that message someone messages you
through Facebook and you hear that Bing
you're gonna look at your phone most
likely well at least probably over an
email or a text message I know I need
personally so I just thought wow I mean
what better way to reach people than
where they spent all their time which is
Facebook message written which is where
the chat bot would be accessible to
people now that I kind of thought about
the benefits of it I was totally
convinced all right I just need to build
this trap lock the process that I use to
build my yoga me chat bob was fairly
straightforward it kind of follows a lot
of the other process for my
side projects but I first thought about
you know why I was building this and how
does to be valuable for people and try
to define that come up with this kind of
chaplain and it was really first off
just idea to find the goal of just
making a place where people can learn
more about me
consume my content and contact me
regarding projects or you know helping
them out if they have any questions
about this when I kind of have that down
then I needed to kind of go into okay
all these channels that I just mentioned
for instance all these medium articles
how do I then include those because
they're already out there there are T
something that I get a ton of really
good feedback on even these YouTube
videos so how do I then package them in
my chat pod because that's the best way
you know to let people consume this
content featured in there so what I came
up with was actually a yoga meet
playbook
so I thought you know what does all the
content cover and it's really about
going from from an idea to MVP to
revenue-generating startup to scale and
even some acquisitions that I've had in
the past so what better way to kind of
package this up and make it easier for
people to navigate and having a yogi
player in my chat box so that's actually
what I did so I repurposed a lot of
medium articles in sequence in a
playbook and also these videos in the
chat bot I'll screenshot here a for the
actual dashboard for track fuels so I
did use chat fuel and I used I actually
took to our chat bot template and I
repurposed it so I simply duplicated
that to create the yoga me bot and then
I simply modified using the blocks the
content that would either so I'll
screenshot here you can see the chat
fuel dashboard and it's actually my
playbook and then it's the about me ask
a question and then it's calm it's
contact me or and then after that is the
actual kind of share so there's a little
reality effect in theirs that people
commit message their other friends
through messenger and share so that's
kind of basic template that I you
used in chat fuel so they're very
straightforward so this took less than
an hour
honestly the when it came down to is
just getting all the existing content
that I had already put out kind of
packaging it up through this chat bot
you know just modifying the templates
and then kind of testing that
conversational interface and design and
just modifying it so I can make it kind
of as natural and smooth as possible
based off of what people actually want
to see and wouldn't be interested in it
after about an element you know hour at
most
I actually had this yummy chat bot line
what I did from that was I actually
responded to some emails that I got from
people asking me questions and I poured
on them towards the link for the chat
pod and and you know just I said hey I'm
going this tripod you know because I get
a lot of questions are similar to yours
here's a direct answered your question
but I would love if he could give me
some feedback on this chat pod that I
just made by literally like 30 minutes
ago so I did that and you know people
were very receptive to that whose own
like five or six at first but I got some
really good feedback so I made some
improvements on that conversational flow
and now that's great so it's like my
first kind of user feedback then from
there I followed a typical kind of
launch framework that I take for
products because this was and it is a
kind of a product it's just my chopped
off for myself featuring my content
packaged up as a playbook but I then
went to bottleless which I know I've
mentioned set the founder bottle is he's
amazing when it comes down the
chocolates he knows everything
will hit his website bot list is a great
place to take your chat bot and get your
first users so I posted on your roomie
bought on bot list which I'll screenshot
the profile here but it got around 4,000
initial views so I'm gonna say maybe a
couple hundred users from not two people
had actually tried it out got a few
people to review it so it's kind of like
an app store
so it was a perfect place for me to
launch from there I've actually taken a
created a bitly short link so I have a
bit li / yoga meet and that's actually
my chatbot link so now instead of just
having my website on my content
everywhere I can actually link directly
to my Chapel and the benefit that is
people can obviously consume that
content and and you know find my
playbook through there but then when
people when people use the chat pod they
can contact me but they're also kind of
a subscribed user so then when I come
out with new content I can actually push
them a message and they'll be the first
to know through my tripod about this new
content that I have coming out so I
actually want to go into another video
talking about now after I've launched
the chat bot how effective traffic mods
can me for sending messages versus
sending emails but I'm gonna keep this
video short you can expect another video
coming up soon talking about that
results but so far I've had some amazing
feedback on it and it seems to be
actually adding value to people that do
have questions and are interested in
taking their idea to an MVP to live--to
revenue generating startup so why don't
you check it out I'll link down here
below the chat bot but comment below let
me know what you think give me some real
honest feedback on it and I definitely
want to improve and hit subscribe so I
keep making these videos see ya
you